il ya une proportion de gens qui mettent
des masques je pense que on ne change
pas sa culture du jour au lendemain mais
quand même on voit qu'on s'adapte très
vite je me souviens ça n'a vraiment rien
à voir mais ça l'analogie émergent de ma
conscience c'est que lorsqu'il ya eu la
pandémie de sida et quand on s'est
aperçu que l'afrique était extrêmement
touché beaucoup de gens avaient des
préjugés disait en afrique
ils mettront pas de préservatif c'est
pas possible c'est pas leur culture
et puis quand les gens ont vu qu'il y
avait des gens qui mouraient dans leurs
proches dans leur famille etc et bien
bien entendu ils ont été comme tout le
monde comme nous sommes tous quoi ils
ont été conscients du problème du risque
et ils se sont mis à mettre des
préservatifs
de la même façon je pense que le mas qui
est en train de devenir un des moyens de
protection
les personnels de santé vous savez au
début les occidentaux les hôpitaux
occidentaux ce n'était pas si facile de
faire porter un masque c'est pas très
agréable de travailler avec la masquer
en plus les passionnés santé ont parfois
des masses qu'on appelle ffp2 qui sont
des masques qui protège encore plus en
particulier quand les gouttelettes
d'aérosols sont sont très fines dans la
presse certaines procédures invasives en
médecine et bien c'est difficile c'est
une masse très hermétique ce n'est pas
très agréable de travailler avec cela et
bien les personnes chantaient les
maîtres remarquablement bien dans les
hôpitaux et d'ailleurs il ya assez peu
de personnel santé qui ont été
contaminés donc je pense que le masque a
prouvé son efficacité de façon
extrêmement emblématique et que face à
cela tout dépend de la perception que
l'on a du risque c'est vrai que quand on
est dans une telle décrue que très peu
de cas surviennent le masque
probablement les gens tombent le masque
si je puis dire et lemaître - sont moins
conscients etc
et dès que l'on verra que le ciel virus
circule à nouveau et qu'on verra une
nouvelle ré émergence du virus
ce que j'espère nous reverrons pas mais
si jamais de des foyers survenait dans
tel ou tel endroit
je suis assez intimement persuadé que
les gens remettrait des masques la chose
que vous dites
en revanche est crucial c'est qu' il
vaut mieux ne pas mettre de masques du
tout que de mettre un masque en base est
tous sous son nez
[Musique]